皆さん2022年もいよいよ終わり年末に
なってきました
すでに買われましたでしょうか
年末
ジャンボ宝くじ
僕はまた貼ってません皆さん買いました
年末ジャンボ宝くじここ数年あんまり買っ
てなかったんですけども今年はマジで強い
かなと思いましててか何円なん今年
ちょっと金額次第みたいなところあるな
値段感がまじでわかんない
え10億円
お金はなんぼあってもええなあ皆さん今年
の年末ジャンボ宝くじ1等前後賞合わせて
10億円当たるらしいです1個だけ言わせ
てくださいあの
[音楽]
買わないと当たらないんですよどうせ
当たんないんだろうなって思って買わ
なかったら当たりません
当たる権利すらもらえないつまり何が言い
たいかというと皆さんとりあえず買わ
なきゃいけない300円でもいいから1個
買っとけば当たる可能性がもうわずかにも
あるので僕もとりあえず買おうかなと思っ
てるんですけど1等が7億円で1等の前後
賞が1億5000万円で連番で買えば中国
ってことか1等23本ってことは全国で
23人の人に10億円が当たる可能性があ
るってことなんで僕今年
買います買いますけども
正直どれぐらい買えばいいかわかんないん
ですよ1つだけ確かなのはたくさん買えば
買うほど当たる確率は上がるそれはもう
間違いないので
[音楽]
皆さんに私始めたちを宝くじ何円分買えば
いいのかちょっと決めてもらうと思います
というわけで今日の企画は
Twitterのリツイートの活文宝くじ
買ったら当たる当たらなーい
[音楽]
正直どれぐらいでも出せます逆にそのどれ
ぐらい買えばいいかわかんないんでそれは
もうあの
視聴者の皆様ネットの皆様に決めてもらう
と思うので今からTwitterで
つぶやくはよしできましたリツイートの数
×100円分年末ジャンボ宝くじ買おうか
な
ここがマジでここはどうしようワールドに
されたらマジでやばいリツイートの数×
100円分なので1万リツイート行ったら
100万円分10万リツイート行ったら
1000万円分買いますちょっと待って
待って本当にやばい
まいっかいいんです
当てるんで絶対俺はもう逆にこれ1億円分
買うことになっても1億円も当たればOK
なんで大丈夫大丈夫
あツイートしたやばいあーツイートした
やばいやばい
削除します
追加して怒られる
わかりづらかったなごめんなちょっと
顔をかなたとなんか確定じゃないからさ
シンプルに行こうごめんごめんちょっと
分かりづらかったね墨汁今日の20時まで
です
ねこれまあでも16万円ぐらいでしょうま
大体これぐらいの時間だったら大丈夫
でしょうあもう1700行ったやばいな今
18時なんであと6時間ぐらいでしょ6
時間でそんな増えないのでまあ行っても
大体1万リツイートぐらいの100万円分
ぐらいになるかなと僕は思いますまあそれ
だけでちょっとわかってる気がするじゃあ
ちょっと
待ちますでは
[音楽]
やばいって
やばいってマジで
ありがとうございますリツイートして
くださった皆様本当にありがとうござい
ますきついとしてくれた方の中には純粋に
俺に10億円当たってほしいってそういう
気持ちで
リツイートしてくれた人たちね破産させ
ちまおうぜみたいな感じでバルふざけてリ
ツイートした人いろんな人がいてこの金額
になってしまったと思いますとりあえず
あのリツイート本当に皆さんしてくださっ
てありがとうございます
ふざけるなというわけで
ヤバ
いやなんかそのお金あるイメージあると
思うけどさ一応金銭感覚狂ってない方の
人間なんよ一応まだ俺はその人の心忘れず
に持ってる方かなと思ってて
会社になってて給料もらってそれで生活し
てるタイプの人間なんでみんなが思ってる
よりそんなお金遊びしてないよ
[音楽]
な
割と心苦しいです
がこれは無駄なお金ではないパンツに通し
てから0時になればです最終的になんで
テストだったのか動画撮ってあるのでそれ
見ていきたいと思います
あ10時になりました
リツイートこれが
えー
7.1番にツイートえー
7.1万
×100円分
710万円
宝くじ
買わせていただきます
やばいって
やばいってマジでさすがにヤバいってー
ありがとう
参加してくれてありがとう
7個準備しましたこれ700万円です見て
ください本当にちゃんと100万円です
マジの100万円がそれがちゃんと
700万円分準備してやりますこれ皆さん
10万円合計710万円で宝くじを
買います
いやなんかその100万円分宝くじ買った
とかもうそんなの
甘いね
甘いというか別に俺も俺はそれぐらいが
良かった
けどもうちょっとあのねあのちょっと自分
の
影響力を勘違いしていたのかもしれない
普通になんか1万リツイートぐらいで
なんか100万200万ぐらいかなと思っ
たらマジ700万についとって
ありがとうとしか言えんなはいすいません
言い出したのは僕なので買わせていただき
ますただマジで無駄にしたくないです俺
マジで絶対やってるから10億円絶対やっ
てますどうやって買うかちょっと今色々
考えてるんで年末に何かとか出ます
710万円しっかり
買って何かしらの形で動画で絶対結果をお
伝えするしなんならちょっとその当たっ
てるかどうか見るところとかも動画にし
たいと思うのでぜひ皆さん本当にほんと
初めに当たってほしいと思ってリピートし
てくれた皆さん
させてやろうぜっていう考えてるバカ
いい意味ですちょっと期待しててください
ちょマジで冗談抜きで
700万710万でしょマジで
あるよ絶対
元は取るもう絶対いやそんなついんけど
考えちゃった
必ず
必ず10億円貸したり待っておい
[音楽]